بالونات اختبار رفع القيود عن كورونا في
الصين اغلبها ايجابيه ونتائجها لا تبعث
على الفرح برقه الامل التي تحدث عنها
الرئيس الشيش جيم بينج لا يمكن رؤيتها هذه
الايام
تكتظلميات وترتفعالات الاصابه بالفيروس
الذي ظهر لاول مره قبل ثلاث سنوات في
وهران كثره الاصابه منذ رفع القيود التي
اضرت كثيرا بالاقتصاد واغضبت العباده دفعت
بيجين الى الغاء نشر الاحصاءات العدوى
والوفيات اليوميه على مستوى البلاد اعترف
في السلطات حجم متفش الوباء اصبح من
المستحيل تتبعها بعد انتهاء تدابير الفحوص
الجماعيه الالزاميه الوضع يستدعي اتخذت
تدابير جديده لحمايه المواطنين كما جاء في
تصريحات الرئيس شيء وهي الاولى منذ رفع
القيود التي عزلت لسنوات ثانيه اكبر
اقتصادا في العالم
وفق دراسات الاستقصائيه غير رسميه ربما
تكون الموجه الاخيره للفيرس قد بلغت
ذروتها في المدن الكبرى للعاصمه بيجين
ومدينه شوكتينغ فرحتو الصينيين بالقدره
على السفر اخيرا لم تدوم كثيرا عدد الدول
التي تفرض قيود على القادمين من هناك في
الزياده ولن يتوقف الرقم عند اثني عشر
بلدا ابرزها الولايات المتحده وكندا
واستراليا وقطر وبعض دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والمملكه المتحده واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه والمغرب تشترط هذه الدول نتيجه
للفحص قبل 48 ساعه من الرحله او اجراء
فحصا عند الوصول الاكثر سلامه هو قرار
المغرب الذي يحضر دخول الوافدين من الصين
مهما كانت جنسيتهم الرد الجماعي الموحد
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي سيعرف يوم الاربعاء
موعد محادثات لي الصحه في التكتل لتنسيق
الاستجابه كما ذكرت الرئاسه السويديه
الحاليه بسياسه صفر كوفد انتقدت الصين
وبدونها هي منتقده اكثر عطله راس السنه
القمريه والتي تستمر اسبوعا بدايه من الحد
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري لن تكون عطله
للفيروسات والمتحورات المعروفه والمجهوله
كورونا والصين مسلسل يبدو ان ثلاثه مواسم
منه غيرك فيها